for decades the rich have used offshore
havens to hide away their money and more
and more investigative journalists have
tried to expose their methods but never
before on this scale
it really kind of pulls back the veil of
secrecy that hangs over this offshore
world
it kind of reveals this global industry
of not just corporate service providers
but bankers lawyers and accountants who
are working quite hard to hide assets
to bend the rules in some cases to break
the rules for those who are wealthy or
powerful enough to pay for it
nearly 12 million confidential files
were leaked to investigators uncovering
the hidden assets of 35 current and
former world leaders more than 300
politicians and public officials
the documents come from 14 offshore
financial service providers based all
around the world
one leader singled out in what
investigators have called the pandora
papers is czech prime minister andrej
babis investigators claim he used
offshore companies to buy a 12 million
dollar chateau in the french riviera
with two swimming pools and a cinema
he has rejected the claims on twitter i
have never done anything illegal or
wrong he said but that doesn't prevent
them from trying to denigrate me again
and influence the czech parliamentary
elections
many other members of the rich the
famous the powerful are singled out in
the papers for using the offshore
financial system to hide their money and
avoid paying tax
and one location comes up more than
others despite all the controversy about
london being used to conceal huge
amounts of money the city remains the
destination of choice for many it seems
desperate to park their cash without too
many questions being asked
dominic waghorn sky news